this is something that is being
destroyed by people who didn't build it
and that's always very important to
remember this city was built up by their
parents and grandparents and
great-grandparents and then they came
along and they tore it down and part of
the reason they tore it down was out of
Envy there are people who have worked
harder than me who have made more
beautiful things than I've made or could
even hope to make or I'm interested in
making and that makes me mad and I want
to rip it all apart and so when they
start to do that by implementing insane
policies that say things like you can
steal and we won't prosecute you as long
as it's less than nine hundred dollars
worth of theft that's occurred
and you rewire people's thinking into
this very insane short-term
um Paradigm that rewards people for
taking and not for making then this is
the exact scenario you end up with you
get destruction and nobody builds
anything why would they you've only
punished them for it